hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new episode of
collider connected it is such an honor
to have delroy lindo
from the five bloods on the show this
time around delroy
huge congratulations and how you doing
right now
i'm doing all right i'm doing okay thank
you harry you i am
doing quite well because i might be
excited to talk to you about your
filmography and
in particular the five bloods which we
cannot be talking about enough right now
but i warned you we like to go back to
the beginning and see how
your filmography has paved the way to
your latest so
really going way back here what movies
and shows were you watching
when you were growing up and now do you
find that any of those past favorites
are influencing the roles that you
gravitate towards today
um the short answer to your question is
i would not say that any of
what i was watching i didn't have a tv
for many many years
when i was um young and so i i don't
necessarily have the tradition of
watching television
in in perhaps the same way that
quite a few other people might so i
don't really have that
um uh history and and therefore
i can't necessarily make a direct
connection
to what i may have watched earlier in my
life
and um
how that impacts my choices now
what i will say is that actually
i am more impacted by some of the things
i saw in the theater
um and that's had much more of an
impact a direct impact direct and
direct and indirect impact
not necessarily so much on my choices as
an actor but
certainly in terms of
[Music]
my belief that i could have a career as
an actor
in the first place um i'm not sure
if you're aware but we just lost on the
weekend
a giant of the theater whose name was
douglas turn award
douglaston award was the artistic
director for many many years
of the negro ensemble company in new
york city
where where are you based where are you
guys at the moment i am in new york
aha okay so i'm not sure how as a
as a new yorker or somebody who lives in
new york how aware you are
of the negro ensemble company and its
history but
they were in the 60s 70s
um it is early to mid 80s
hugely influential in the theater
and in fact when i
came back to new york from
[Music]
studying at the american conservatory
theater in san francisco
the very fir i had two auditions set up
uh one was at the public theater the new
york
shakespeare festival and the other was
and i believe the very
first audition was what we used to call
a
general audition for nec
so let me go ensemble company i had seen
a production broadway production of the
river niger
um in 1973
and i've told various of your colleagues
that
as a result of seeing that when i walked
out of the theater
i had an enhanced sense
after having witnessed a group of black
hackers on stage
in front of me with i was sitting in the
balcony
with a group of black people in the
audience
neither of which i had seen
neither of which i had experienced um
at that point in my life and it was
hugely impactful for me
and when i walked out of the theater as
a result of that experience
i had a an enhanced
sense that maybe somehow
i could have a career as a theater as a
i'm sorry i could have a career as an
actor
um so
i would say some of the things i saw in
the theater
[Music]
um influence me
impacted me much more directly
rather than things i saw on television
so just to make sure i have that early
timeline right
when you were studying acting in school
at that point did you have the ambition
of being
a screen actor and then the general
opportunity at nec
came up and it kind of put you down that
path instead
not at all i i had no sense of wanting
to become a screen actor
i had a sense of wanting to become an
actor
and i wanted very specifically to work
in the theater
because i
had this sense and i would say that i am
part of a generation of theater actors
that had
the sense in the past and i would say
this is in the um
mid to late 1970s
um but i would say that the ethos
probably started much sooner than when i
started working and that that ethos that
belief
was that theater could change the world
and
i certainly um have modified
that um that belief
um subsequent
to to to that time but i do believe that
work can have an impact
on if not change the world per se
it can certainly have an impact
on or in the world that one is a part of
so i wanted to become a theater actor i
was not
thinking about the screen and
and that desire to want to work
as a screen actor came much much later
for me
so in that case one what sparked that
initial desire and when the first
on-screen opportunities rolled around
is there anything in particular that
opened your mind up to those
possibilities as well and the impact
that that format can make
okay um
the various realizations
and for one of the better term
maybe epiphanies regarding
the impact that working in film
working for the screen can have i've had
different realizations of that and i i
i'll give you a
kind of an anecdote but to your question
um uh
after working in the theater my
my career in the theater essentially
started
um i would say in 1980
and i worked
almost exclusively as a new york based
theater actor for the first 10 years of
my career
pretty much ish from 1980 to 1990.
in that period um
[Music]
as a new york based theater actor every
now and again
i would do small parts in tv shows or in
films that would come to town to cast
but
generally my work was in the theater
in approximately the mid 1980s at which
point i was working
fairly consistently as a theater actor
and i should stress to you that that
work
pretty much involved working in the
regional theater
in this country um yes i've been on
broadway a couple of times
yes i've played off broadway a a few
times
but broadly speaking
generally speaking a lot of the work
that i did was in the regional theater
um and i came to the realization
probably in the mid 1980s even though i
was working
fairly consistently in the theater that
i needed to make more money
i needed to make more money one and i
also had a
very clear sense that if i wanted to
expand my career as an actor i needed to
work for the camera
which at that point meant for me working
in quote unquote television and
the reason that i came to that realistic
realization aside from the money
the reason that creatively quote-unquote
i came to that realization
is because what was happening
for me was that when films for instance
would come to new york to cast
i felt that the new york theater actors
while they had the respect creatively
would invariably just get um the
opportunity to audition for
the smaller parts what we used to call
bit parts
that would work one or two days on a
particular film
and i felt
certainly that was my experience um
that they were the kinds of
opportunities though they were few and
far between
but when i did get an opportunity to
audition for something in film
it was invariably a smaller role
and i felt two things i
felt i was even at that point in my
career
better than the opportunities that were
being
given to me to audition
and i felt
um that if i continued
in that paradigm just staying in new
york
auditioning when i got the chance for
these smaller parts that would come in
to new york to cast
i i started to feel like i was a little
bit on a treadmill
um and that i didn't really see the
opportunities that i could broaden my
career
so i would say that happened
around the mid-1980s
um that i came to that that realization
and i and interestingly i would say to
you that
the realization was creative
rather than oh i need to make more money
that was certainly part of it
but it was a creative realization oh if
i want to
grow my career expand my career as an
actor i need to somehow start working
for television and film
and in that regard the theater and a
couple of parts that i did in the
theater
fed directly into the opportunities in
film that came to me a little later so
it was all
it was all generated by my work in the
theater
so given what you're saying about the
creative drive and also the financials
of it all
and this is something i'm always
interested in hearing about because i
think
in this industry no matter what medium
you work in it's a very difficult thing
to say no
to an opportunity when it presents
itself but of course
you know you said no to do the right
thing so
with that particular example and maybe
anything else like that that came your
way
how do you find that balance between
taking the opportunities you need to
forge forward but also saying no to
things that don't speak to you
in the mid 1980s i had an extraordinary
creative period in the theater
i went to the
kennedy center dc the eisenhower theater
in in
in in dc as part of the kennedy center
with a production of a raisin in the sun
i was i was playing walter lee in a
raisin son one of the
great parts it was an extremely
successful
production as a result of the success
of that production we took the
production
to los angeles and we played at the
wilshire theater on wilshire avenue
again very very um
successful as a result of that
i went in and auditioned
and received an offer
to play a part in a tv show that was
just starting
at the time called beauty and the beast
uh ron
i can't remember the actor's name and
he's a good actor and i'm
i'm embarrassed right now he played the
beast
and then the hamilton played the beauty
um so i got this part in beauty and the
beast
and i did the first episode
i then went back to new york
and or i did an episode maybe i think it
was the pilot episode
but then i went to do after doing walter
lee
in the theater i then went to do a play
called
joe turner's come and gone a brilliant
brilliant
brilliant play by august wilson
um so i had this experience of doing
walter lee younger in the theater then i
did this
tv show this pilot then i did
um joe turner's come and gone
in the theater i was being i was being
challenged to do these great great parts
the character i played
and joe turner has come and gone his
name is
harold loomis about a man looking for
his wife by extension the play is about
african descended people looking for
themselves
on the american uh in america
all right i think i did
two productions regionally
of joe turner's come and gone
i then got an opportunity
to audition
in los angeles for a film
that nick nolte was doing and i can't
remember the
name of the film
but i had i auditioned in new york for
this film
they flew me out to los angeles for a
for a
callback audition it was a bizarre
experience
it was just bizarre we don't have time
to go into it but it was just a really
bizarre experience i didn't get the part
and i remember
sitting on the plane flying back to new
york thinking
about this audition that i had done what
was that i was just
what was that but what saved me
was that i was going to do another
production of
joe turner's come and gone i had that
i then got a call from the producer
of beauty and the beast his name was ron
koslow
and ron wanted me to come back and do
another episode of beauty and the beast
and the timeline conflicted with my
commitment
to go and do this
next the following production of joe
turner's come and gone and i said no
there isn't and he could not understand
it
i i said ron i i can't ron koslow had
been very very gracious toward me
um he wanted me to come back and do this
episode
and as i weighed the creative dividend
of going to do another episode of
beauty and the beast compared to
the creative dividend of doing herod
loomis
and joe turner's come and gone there
simply was
no comparison so i turned down
going back to do another episode of of
beauty and the beast i stayed with the
production
of joe turner's come and gone which
ended up
uh going to broadway spike lee
saw me on broadway and joe turner's come
and gone
which started the connection the
relationship between myself
and spike
that's a very long-winded answer i hope
you followed it
but it's pertinent to your question
there's an important story for the whole
purpose of collider connected so i
appreciate you sharing that
i feel like i'm taking a very big leap
forward but
you just brought up earlier the idea of
bit parts in movies and shows and the
thing that came out i don't like that
term
i'm sorry i'm sorry to interrupt you but
i hate that term it's it's it's
it's insulting to actors in the process
but you know
smaller parts parts that played in in
films for
one or two days you know those kinds of
points yes i respect that shift there
quite a bit
the movie that came to mind when you
were explaining that was the devil's
advocate
because i don't necessarily know how the
behind the scenes of credits work but i
look at that
and i wonder why you're uncredited in
that movie and i wonder if it has
anything to do with the size of the role
no it has absolutely nothing to do with
the size of
the role um i had worked with taylor
hackford the director of the devil's
advocate
i had worked with taylor on a film
called uh blood in blood out
um and uh we shot on
among other locations which i shot on
location in san quentin
um and uh
taylor called me and asked me to do this
part
in devil's advocate
and i looked at the part
and by that time and i'm not sure what
year devil's advocate was
97 okay so at that point
i was working in film more consistently
and it wasn't that the part was not
interesting
i just felt when taylor called me and
asked me to do that
i just felt i had i was i was doing
you know larger parts more substantial
parts on film
and so i graciously i did two things
i graciously declined um his offer
but i also recommended another actor
to taylor i said
taylor i i'm going to pass on this man
but why don't you
cast and i i named an actor that i had
worked with
and i said why don't you cast this guy
he's really good he'll be great in this
part etc
for whatever reason it did not work it
didn't work out with that other actor
taylor came back to me and said man do
me a favor
i really want you to do this part so i
did it
um i was very well paid for
one day of work and i don't remember the
specifics of
why i i i i think
the reason i i am uncredited in the film
is because my agent at the time
um wonderful agent brilliant agent
said you know what because it is a
smaller part
uh and and how you know how are they
going to
and del roy lindo how are we going to
figure out the
the billing on this so the and we
we kind of sort of couldn't figure out
the billing because i was coming to the
project
late and maybe the and position was
already taken
i don't remember but we for whatever
reason we couldn't figure out the
billing so he said look
the work you've been doing you know and
at that point i had done malcolm x i had
done crookman i had done get shorty i
had done clockers
so at that point he said to me look
people will know it's you
so just take an uncredited do the job do
the work
and just don't take a credit nobody's
going to say
who's that actor i mean they they will
know you
you're you're you're well known enough
you can afford to
be uncredited and i i also so that's the
reason that i was uncredited and also at
that time the mid 1970s 1977
1997 there was a kind of a trend
of certain actors being uncredited in
certain films
so that that's why i was unc i was
uncreated
i have to take a step back and if i have
my timeline right it's two years because
i watched congo a lot the line in this
house that is repeated from that movie
the most
i know what the line is stop eating my
sesame cake
i'm like i'm totally serious and asking
you this
what was that scripted and how do you
figure out how to nail
the delivery of a line of dialogue like
that because if
it is iconic yeah it's become a thing
huh um
i'm fairly certain that it was scripted
um and it was another instance in which
i was very well paid for literally one
day of
work um
when i first was off at that part i
believe it was going
to shoot in the dominican republic and
they said the producer said look
uh will you come do this part um
we're shooting in the dominican um you
can bring your wife
you know you can film for a day or two
on the film and then you can
spend some time in the dominican
republic and i said oh great fantastic
yes i'll do the part um
time evolved and we ended up shooting in
pasadena
um i did get to bring my wife but we
went to pasadena another dominican
republic
um but the line was scripted and it was
one of those things where i just went in
and um
did the work that was in front of me was
really good actors in the cast
um and we just worked and it just
happened and it's one of those things
that has become
you know your word is iconic it's become
a thing i i'm
clear it's become a thing and it's the
connection that many many people make
for my contribution to that film it's
not even that line though
your entire sequence your delivery kind
of carries it i mean
liar and i are saying more it's like
teeny tiny little things that could be
insignificant like that
you make sure it becomes like an ear
worm of sorts because of the way you
deliver it
well thank you i appreciate that and
perhaps
to my earlier point right of not
referring
to bit parts you know it i i guess it's
an example of
how an actor how any of us invests
in the words that are in front of us in
a script
and that will dictate what you get out
of it as an actor in terms of the
creative process
but also the potential impact on
audiences you always do that i feel like
i'm jumping so far ahead but i want to
save
a chunk of time for the five bloods but
another one that really intrigues me on
your resume
is up because i don't know i would have
thought that your filmography would have
been
filled with voice acting opportunities
so how did
up come along and was voice acting
something you had been interested in
prior to that offer
voice acting absolutely was something i
was
and am interested in prior to that offer
and it came to me and i've never had a
i've never had a voice agent
either i i've never been with an
agency that pushed that aspect of what i
potentially have and i've also never had
a voice agent
who could do that so the voice work that
i've done has been
very very very intermittent and sparse
but having said that i am
really glad i did up um for a variety of
reasons
um and and it came to me um the
uh pixar um basically
you know made
that offer to me and i remember them
saying
um you know
you know how how do you feel about
playing a dog
and and i i had to think about that
and as as they presented
the script to me and as i recall it's
it's strange working as a voice actor in
a pixar film
and as much as you're not seeing the
finished product
you're seeing drawings you're seeing
bits of of um
the narrative and and the material but
it's in
in the form of drawings and um
i thought about what playing a dog well
i i guess i'm okay with it i'm what do
you guys have in mind
and we talked about it we talked it out
and by the time we had a
back and forth discussion i decided that
okay
sure i can i can do that but the answer
to your question is um
um yeah i'm i'm very much interested in
continuing to do voice work
i'd like to see it happen even with all
your experience up to that point is
there anything new you learned about
your craft by
stripping the physicality away and only
being able to focus on the voice work
great question yes yes
i guess what i learned that process
involves having a dependence on the
instrument and having a dependence on
the imagination my own imagination
to um bring together
the the journey of the of the character
and
and that's not very clear if i'm looking
at a drawing
literally a drawing on a screen of what
my
character will potentially look like i
am then presented with
the um what we call the
the the circumstances of the story at a
given time
and how i am then connecting to the
circumstances in the story
how i am connecting to the narrative as
it unfolds
it is then incumbent on me as the
creative person
to flesh that out and bring to it
as much emotional vitality and as much
emotional light as i am able even
in that relatively bare bones setting
but what i am depending on
ultimately is my own
creativity to bring it alive
um and i that's that's a test
for any actor it's a challenge but
um i guess i i don't know if i
i guess i learned that i am able to do
that
and that does speak to um
i don't know my training the years that
i've worked and everything that i bring
to a given creative situation
i'm eager to see you do that again
i mean again the five bloods
i i kind of think i know the answer to
this one but when you first signed on
for that role what was the part of it
that required you to i guess do the most
work
in order to be able to connect to paul
foley the answer is maybe
not quite what you think i mean
certainly i know you've read
the the trumpian hesitancy that i had
and that was work
in in terms of getting my head around
rationalizing
how the character could have cast that
vote in 2016.
so that's one aspect but i would say the
work
there was a huge amount of work for me
uh
from the standpoint of deconstructing
the condition of
ptsd which is fundamental to paul
which is um part of what
a major part of what paul is struggling
with in negotiating
and so that involved um
meeting and talking with vets reading um
literature
and and and and watching film so
the the work there was
uh a central part of the what i call you
know the research
process leading up to and
continuing leading up to production and
continuing
throughout production but i would say
that
the conversations that i had with
various vets the first two of whom were
my cousin that i've
talked about a lot my two cousins that i
have
who were vets that was the
that was a lot of the meat of the
preparation
to do that work um getting to terms with
okay how has ptsd affected
what are the effects what are the
impacts of ptsd on these various people
that i spoke with
how do i translate that into paul's
experience
incorporate that into this character i'm
creating
so throughout the movie as you're
expressing that
i mean paul really requires you to be at
i guess an 11
from start to finish there are so many
scenes in this movie that i imagine are
immensely challenging uh
the argument with otis the landmine
sequence the shootouts the
the monologues you deliver straight to
camera of all of that is there any
particular one that made you circle that
day
on the filming schedule and say that day
is the one that intimidates me the most
no um no i i don't say that
from the standpoint of being arrogant um
i was not intimidated
i'll tell you something i was not
intimidated
a because i i trusted
my preparation i trusted the work that i
had done to prepare
and that is not to say when i walked on
set
i was thinking to myself oh i'm prepared
it was not that it was just
i trusted those aspects of my process
but i also had a director in spite me
who trusted me and created a safe space
for all of us to work
therefore there was no single
day that said ooh i'm intimidated by
that
certainly there were days that were that
contained big scenes
but the trust that had been established
my trust in the way that i was working
the way that i was approaching the work
and the trusted spike lee places in me
all of those things are huge positives
to make the overall process of doing the
work
safe and honestly i
intimidation is not a word that i would
use um
being intimidated certainly challenged
challenged but
i had a sense that look
clearly had things not been going
well or had things
been such that spike was um dissatisfied
with anything that i
or any of the rest of us were doing he
absolutely would have made that known
and he didn't so there was a there was a
smoothness
to the um that's not the most
appropriate word
there was a
one felt the the the
i use analogy and i use the analogy
sometimes but train
one felt that the train was going in the
direction that it needed to go in
and that we were all on it together and
spike was at the helm
and he was appreciating
what he was getting in terms of the
serving of the narrative does that make
sense absolutely
you also spoke of safety on set
from spike as a leader and i always love
asking about what you get from your
co-stars as well and the moment that i
wanted to focus on was
the forgiveness beat between you and
chadwick and
what he can do for you in an emotional
moment like that
to best support you and bring the most
out of your work
what you can do what chad we did and
what you can do
is hold up your end of the scene
there are two of us in the scene i've
got my i have to hold up
my end and the other actor has to hold
up his or her
end and what you can do is hold up your
end
additionally in addition to
holding up your end what
extra can you bring to elevate
the work and it it's very interesting
um
[Music]
chadwicks chadwick's wife
now wife simone said
something to me about that scene
a few days after we had shot it and it
was just something i
in terms of the impact of the scene on
her
and all the people who were watching us
work and it just hadn't occurred to me
in those kinds of terms she said and i
said oh wow
thank you um she said it was magical
and
it he said it was magical watching it
watching us and um
what more can an actor ask for
in the work than to have that kind of
impact
on uh anybody watching
and the fact that it was um
as i have talked about frequently at
this point the fact that it that was
that it was chadwick's first day of work
just enhanced exponentially my
appreciation of the whole
seeing the day the work in general
it was his first day of work i had been
working for five
six weeks at that point and he showed he
showed up
and not only did he hold his end up of
the same
he contributed
over and above what was on the written
page
that is what any actor can do
to contribute to the work of
his or her scene partner in a scene
i've seen him create that magic in two
different movies now over the past year
and to even be able to feel like a
little bit of that spark
is so greatly appreciated appreciated
and i'm just like
i'm in awe of his ability
i do want to highlight some of your
other co-cast
right now because the five bloods does
feature one of my favorite ensembles
of the past year so of everybody that
you're working opposite here
who would you say has a process that's
most similar to yours
and then who challenged you to adapt the
most
each of the styles of acting that we
brought
to this work were
quite seamlessly incorporated into what
what each of us was doing
does that make sense absolutely
in terms of who challenged me to it no
whose
work is similar to my own um i
can't answer that fully
but i will say that jonathan majors
before we started working
jonathan said amen can i get your number
a couple things i want to talk to you
about
and i said sure man and i was working i
was in production on something else
but i said sure and we jonathan and i
talked
and jonathan asked me a couple of
questions
having to do with the history our
history as father and son
and ironically i couldn't answer the
ques his questions at that time because
i didn't know enough about
about the character i was you know
hadn't started quite creating yet
but the fact that he asked me the
questions that he asked me
led me to understand that
um who
a given character is before the audience
sees him in the story
is important to jonathan answering
certain questions
about who is this person um
and that is something that is uh very
important
for me that i answer those questions um
for myself and that i have knowledge of
the character that i know who this
person is
um before the before i opened my mouth
and started speaking
in whatever scene so
the fact that jonathan asked me those
questions suggests to me that he has a
similar
approach in terms of history of the
characters playing or
biographic certain biographical details
that are important to him
to answer for himself
now i got in the habit the last few
years of asking this a lot
this time of year because personally i
can't get enough
of award season i love the opportunity
to celebrate people's work and
accomplishments i love how
recognition like this can open doors
that weren't open before they can
inspire
change so for you personally what does
award season mean to you why is this
time of year so special for the industry
what it means to me and why it's special
to the industry are two i think very
different things
i i i concur
with you with regard to
it's it's wonderful
that actors get recognition for what
what they have done
it's unfortunate that
i think it's important that it not
become a competition
even though on some level we aren't
competing and that's the unfortunate
part
but i would say that certainly from the
standpoint of giving actors recognition
that's absolutely tremendous and i you
know i'm a member of the academy
and so many many years during award
season i i
oftentimes i get i get to watch
extraordinary work
excuse me and that's um
really really you know gratifying
rewarding
inspiring to see the depth
and the breadth the magnitude
of the talent that's out there and on
and on display
kind of gotta be frank about this last
one here because
the golden globes are on my mind we're
recording this interview the day after
the ceremony
so what i know what went mut through my
mind when i heard the nominations
what goes through your mind when there's
so much positivity and buzz and support
behind you
and then not only your personal
nomination
but the five bloods is nowhere to be
found
in that nomination list because like it
hurt me
i can't even imagine how it made you and
the team feel
it reminded me
that certain pockets of the industry
certain pockets of this process are
still a business
and it being a business
the connection between the business
and the creative aspect do not always
align and i was reminded of that
very starkly very acutely
in that moment that the
uh nominations for the golden globes
were announced what is
something actionable that you think
folks in the industry could do
to change that even when it's not in an
or it's not an organization that you're
necessarily a part of
i always think it's worthwhile talking
about the possibilities to at least
spark that change
right and again i think that is an
entirely
legitimate question um
it's very difficult for me to answer
that question
this year as it as it relates to the
golden globes
because i feel that anything that i say
will be seen as sour grapes perhaps
and i'm not trying to set myself up to
be
assessed in that regard you know
interestingly perhaps if you
if i were not so directly involved in an
awards season this year
and on another year i might be able to
answer that more
quote unquote objectively um
but having said that i would say that
i i hope it is being looked at not just
in terms of me
because the fact is as you know if
you're an award
season fan you know that every single
year
there are worthy performances that get
ignored
i mean the thing and i'm not maybe i'll
get in trouble for saying this but i
cannot understand at all
how alfred woodard's work last year in
clemency
was not lauded
more widely every year it happens that
there are worthy performances
that for whatever reason
don't get the recognition so
as it relates to this year i think this
year is particularly
egregious and i think
and i can only hope that that
process is deconstructed
and looked into because if you're going
to call yourself a legitimate
awards giving organization
then
how are you functioning what are you
recognizing and why
now they may say well we don't have to
answer that question and you're right
you don't
you don't quote unquote oh me or perhaps
anybody else there
but when um
it involves such a
seemingly blatant
um non-reaction
if you were hurt as a as an observer
i really should stop because i mean
um i i just think you asked a legitimate
question
i think it is a legitimate question to
say
okay what's what's going on here what's
really going on here
and smarter minds than myself will
perhaps answer that question or
investigate that i appreciate you
sharing
what you did and for what it's worth
i am rooting for you and for this movie
so hardcore
for anybody out there who is yet to see
the five bloods what are you waiting for
it's streaming on netflix you can go
check it out and then
come jump on uh team delroy here i am
so happy for you congratulations on all
of your success your success with the
five bloods and for
everything i know that is to come for
you i appreciate your time today
god bless you thank you very much i
appreciate it